[Aplausos]
[Música]
Y
mi
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mi
[Música]
la escuela debe volver a convertirse en una máquina
hacer gente francesa gente francesa
asimilado con un perfecto dominio de
el lenguaje es una historia de francia
volver a centrarse en su cronología y eso es
muchos más trigos gloriosos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
por ejemplo el muro fronterizo que
que impide que los migrantes pasen i
encontrarlo interesante, por ejemplo
medir contra quienes luchan contra
influencias de de soros en la universidad
donde la ley que prohibe no
la homosexualidad como estúpidamente repetimos
en francia pero que prohibe la
presencia de grupos de presión lgbt en la escuela
primario
[Aplausos]
[Música]
metro
ya no es hora de reformar el
francia pero para salvarla por eso
he decidido presentarme a las elecciones
presidencial
Por lo tanto, he decidido buscar su
votos convertirse en su presidente de la
República
eres el único productor de renombre
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mi
Y
metro
diferente lo contagiamos él es un
hombre de negocios como dicen que es un
multimillonario yo soy un hombre de
escribir tengo un escritor un periodista
no es lo mismo que el futuro
la política y en esta alianza y yo
Pienso eso cada vez que llego
comparar con donald trump yo no
no sufriré y yo al contrario yo
estaría bastante orgulloso de ello
[Música]
[Aplausos]